well it's good to be back on schedule
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 47 so I'm
tired of people trying to cash in on my
childhood hogs crazy bones yo-yos
pokemon cards the TV shows that
bewitched us the commercials we sat
through the movies that changed our
lives
these things are strung into my heart
with a special talk that's sensitive so
that every cheap tug can make me feel
something like but not quite genuine
emotion maybe you've seen the recently
released ad for Internet Explorer called
child of the 90s I can't show it for
copyright reasons but I put a link in
the description if you want to watch it
essentially the ad is a collection of
those fads and items from the childhood
years of my generation nothing more
certainly and I don't know if you could
do anything less it's a terrible ad that
plays cheaply on a single emotion not
unlike those hard commercials for ASPCA
that show you know watery eye dogs to
the music of Sarah McLachlan whereas the
ASPCA commercial exploits our natural
sympathy and pity poorly for a good
cause the internet explorer' ad exploits
our nostalgia for the lone cause of
profit now of course the exploitation of
human emotion for profit is what makes
the entire industry of advertising
despicable and reprehensible but as we
are hardly any of us unconnected to it
now we speak hypocritically when we
vilify though I've always contended
citing my hypocritical vilification that
it can never be art with the capital a
advertising at it's very best can be so
artful so nuanced and spectacular that
it becomes a hotbed of original creative
ideas from which artists of every medium
can steal and use to their event at its
worst advertising cherry-picks easy
sentiments and pounds them over and over
again until we're all suffering from
blunt force emotional trauma
we've been watching ads for a long time
we know these things the difference and
nothing makes this more clear than the
child of the 90s ad is that now we my
generation is the target now we're
working in TV like I do you hear that
term tossed around a lot the demo how
did we do in the demo are we performing
well in the demo the ratings weren't
great but it's okay because the demo was
good demo is of course short for
demographic just a particular section of
the population but when people say the
demo they're talking about a very
specific group they're talking about
people from the ages of 18 to 49 these
are the golden geese the people to whom
the gross majority of advertising and
commercial entertainment is ain't why
well because we have the money with the
invention of people meters in the early
80s advertisers could see not only what
people were watching but who was
watching what in the early 1970s ABC the
last-place Network unable to pull in a
wide swath and audience sold what they
had which was younger viewers and the
demo was more total viewing numbers
matter less than performance in the demo
a good example of this is the Simpsons
to show that routinely ranked somewhere
in the 60s of the most watched shows but
the average viewer of the Simpsons is 29
years old and that means that the
Simpsons can charge more per commercial
than many of the highest-ranked show
it's all predicated on the notion that
young people young professionals like me
have disposable income that were more
likely to spend than older people not
only that we're more likely to find
brands now that we'll stick with for a
lifetime we have the money advertisers
want the money and TV shows want the
advertisers these are deeply ingrained
relationships determining much of what
you see and our soul we've passed into
the black heart of the demo now and that
means that everything is up for grabs
including and especially our memory
knick knacks from the 90s when life
wasn't so terribly depressed by the idea
of rent forever
when social media didn't exist when life
was homework and home-cooked meals and
everything now when these things in
their own time give way to the new more
complicated and meaningless things of
the future it will all be used and every
sensitive heart string will be pulled
and the generous rosy Brita filter of
memory will be exploited so that the
perfect time of then will unfold before
our eyes inglorious escape and the own
way back there is to download the newest
version of Internet Explorer hey
everybody thanks for watching I wanted
to remind you to follow me on tumblr I
love Tumblr now it's just a great place
to put the images and things that
inspire me all in one place also I am
getting better at Twitter sort of
learning how to communicate
interestingly on that site so follow me
at the nerdwriter both those things are
in the description and I will see you
next time